the Joe Rogan experience when do you
think the people should be able to like
talk again the person yeah that's a good
question well Alex Jones at least says
infowars.com he could do that people go
to that and Gavin's got a show herself
does he
yes he's telling you to but they kick
him off of you dude you don't know if
he's on YouTube because they they kicked
him off a lot of things a little while
ago and it didn't seem like there was a
clear reason it's like they just decided
they were gonna get rid of him
interesting I'm saying like he had been
on he had some scandals but he had
stayed on YouTube right and basically
followed the rules right so what
happened oh it is he son he's definitely
still on oh ok so he's still on ok
so heat that's interesting too right and
then I think he they have their own
thing and if you go on Telegraph they're
all there they're all hanging out it's
like the where it's like microblogging
service and I think Milo's there and
Gavin's there and it's a little bit like
Twitter but it's kind of like for the
band and for people who for the misc
yeah I saw he was he was on one of those
things gab or something like that
talking about Milo was actual numbers he
reaches now how unsustainable it is
obviously there's a lot of people that
like him and there's a look he's a funny
guy he says funny [ __ ] he really does
and I don't I don't think he's been
accurately portrayed I don't I mean I
think he definitely said some stupid
[ __ ] but that's part of the fun of what
he was doing he's a provocateur you know
and he was definitely doing some stuff
that there's like there's a question of
whether or not there was multiple counts
that they were using that he was using -
yeah you know anonymous accounts that's
that was an accusation but Twitter
didn't want to substantiate that when I
talked to them about it because isn't
there word about the legal ramifications
we address that yeah it's it's
problematic because you end up you know
as someone who's kind of for all for
free speech I often get told that I'm
bad because I and I have to defend
people whose language I don't agree with
that is what free speech is it's not
defending everyone who says things that
I love it doesn't make any sense because
that means you're right all the time
like if you're only defending the things
that you believe in
yeah you've write all the time about
everything but I have to defend the
people who say things are even atrocious
than that I can't I would never get on
board with because in that's what free
speech is otherwise and like you said it
is that slippery slope of who gets to be
the arbiter of what is said right and
what are you what are your guidelines
and when I'm saying this about letting
people do it like or arguing against
ideas that you don't agree with like you
should be able to or not to you should
be able to express yourself and respond
to the criticisms that you receive orden
or choose not to yeah but the idea that
only my ideas should get broadcast
because your ideas are contrary to my
ideas I'm gonna cut off the pipeline for
you to express those and work those out
and look there's a lot of people that
had some terrible ideas early in their
life and then they changed yeah is that
um there's that guy what's his name
Christian Pete Cellini
who was in the KKK he was some sort of
white supremacist organization when he
was young and now he talks about the
dangers of these organizations it's like
maybe when I was young people change and
you have to be able to if there's no
path to redemption right what is the
point right so we leave people with
nothing nothing and and hopelessness is
the worst so if you're taking everything
away from somebody and then you're
saying you're you're in the bad place
now forever yeah um what is their
incentive to even open their mind and
have a different why not just double
down let's give a recent example here's
a Greeson example a good one London real
London real had interview with David
Icke I don't know people okay what is
real is a popular YouTube show okay and
they had an interview with David Icke
David Icke is a conspiracy theorist and
thinks that the elites turn into lizards
he says have seen their eyes shift okay
this is he talked about it on this
podcast seeing their eyes shift yes I've
seen their eye shed
okay right there you should be like okay
this is fun this is fun time this guy
thinks that the [ __ ] the Queen's and
lizard lady right but you want to look
out for people that are so [ __ ] dumb
that they're like whoa did you hear
about the lizard people yeah they're
really there's people hey so what right
so what okay great this is evolution
here we're stopping we're stopping the
flow of evolution because if if look
this is how I feel about televangelists
right if you're so dumb you want to give
Joel Olsteen all your money even though
you're poor because you think that
somehow others is gonna save you and
God's grace is gonna be upon you because
you you tithe all your money to Joel
Olsteen he drives around to Bentley and
you're happy for him yeah okay that's
that's legal yeah as dumb as [ __ ] but it
doesn't work on you it works on only the
dumbest of dumb piece so they're like oh
I guess it's okay this is the same thing
yeah it's the same thing if you're so
[ __ ] dumb you really believe that
David Icke seen people's eyeballs shift
over and that there's lizards that are
secretly transforming into politicians
and then going back to lizards when no
one's looking come on
yeah come on so if you take that guy off
you just make them bigger yeah there's a
giant story yeah that this David Icke
podcast was removed from YouTube it
keeps getting removed people keep
uploading it it's like that planned emic
documentary that everybody keeps sending
me oh yeah yeah it gets removed and then
people upload it everywhere we're gonna
upload it everywhere they're trying to
hide the truth just leave it alone
it makes it seem a [ __ ] about that David
Icke interview I mean it would because
it's on London real and it's a popular
program so some people were to watch it
but nobody would have really thought
that the [ __ ] lizard people are there
nobody would in the people that do think
that they're gonna think anything you
could talk them into cutting their balls
off and ride the [ __ ] comment and
join but the thing is like you gotta let
that exist yeah you gotta let these web
but they will with some [ __ ] they will
with the Flat Earth people yeah it's
weird maybe ladders should have still up
oh I know I know
but they get to the five gene they're
like nope too much teaching my ass so
David Icke was talking about 5g
said I don't even what I read brother I
don't even accidental thing but I don't
even think he was saying that 5g causes
it but he was doing some why he was
doing some wacky we literally a weird a
tequila conspiracy [ __ ] yeah living just
weird weird yeah it's only getting
weirder but here's what's interesting
okay this is what we need to accept
about people like David Icke and a lot
of these people there is clearly a lot
of entertainment value and someone
saying preposterous [ __ ] that any
intelligent person knows is not true
there's some weird entertainment value
and someone that really does believe
that aliens live amongst us and that
they're shapeshifters and that if you
look back all of our leaders of all been
you related together and their per guard
of one gene pool that the ancient
Sumerians brought together they came
here from pranit Nibiru and there's
there's something I mean really
entertaining a biology not just
Scientology there's there's a lot a lot
of it right so people watch my youtube
show now I know but I'm saying like
there's a this isn't it's kind of an art
form
mmm this is what I'm thinking it's an
arm entirety it's a kind of performance
art along with like a little bit of
horseshit
and some people is that crazy stand-up
guy Andy Kaufman yes it's like
everyone's meet I'm Andy Kaufman right
Alex Jones is funny than Andy Kaufman
has ever been Alex Jones is [ __ ]
hilarious often did you see the whole
bill that he's Bill Hicks don't
conspiracy I went down there that's the
silliest [ __ ] I know but there are
videos but he had a one thing we're
talking about like if it's between his
family starving or eating his neighbor
I'll eat your ass
I became this jack come on do you don't
think there's an entertainment value and
him saying if it is neighbor back right
but there's something to that like to
bet to stop that and ban that you're
you're not that you're not stopping
anyone from you know you're not stopping
any
buddy from anything bad by not having
Alex do this entertaining thing about
eating his neighbor you're not saving
anybody yeah you know I'm saying but you
got it
you got it like what are you doing like
what is he doing it's so awful
I don't know how to fix any of it cuz
it's it's entertaining like why is it
only acceptable if you have some kind of
entertainment because there's so many
rap videos that you could watch that I
enjoy but they're talking about shooting
people and robbing people and it's
everywhere on YouTube yeah so prevalent
yeah and somehow no that's okay like
it's [ __ ] weird what's allowed and
what's not allowed
[Applause]